[Music]
goddammit Colonel what the were you
doing I'll make it sick beats how do you
break a turntable in half I mean there
were some really sick beads very you
have no respect for other people's stuff
I have no respect for other people's
stuff you and Rakhal even though
she was my girlfriend you have no
respect for other people's stuff Sandra
Connolly isn't stuff colonel and that
was ten years ago get over it
oh I'm over at Vinny I'm over you I'm
done letting you boss me around you
buy me this turntable okay this
is the last time I'll let you boss me
around let me help you set it up any no
that's okay you might break it with your
sick beats which aren't sick at all by
the way what are you telling me if any
I'm telling you your beats suck huh yeah
that's right but not on the dicks people
like to suck your beats suck on the bad
kinds of dicks nightmare dicks you watch
it Vinny one of these days you're gonna
push me too far and you'll be sorry
oh yeah that reminds me tell your mom I
said thanks for the hot sex what did you
just say to me last week at Dave's party
I banged your mom man I banged
her good touched her dirty tuna salad
she loved it I'll kill you you
damn thirty years than that crap
past her table feels good to stretch my
legs let these nothing
y'all got any percocet no are you full
up man she needs a genie and I'm here to
say you got your way but there's
I grant you wishes I don't bread
there's no more gas bitches and still if
you wanna know where I could score some
pills holler at your boy whoa GD what
are we gonna wish for if any we why
would you get wishes it's my turntable
I bought it though with money you stole
from your mom who you banged apparently
dude I was just kidding about that oh
really
nah I totally her man man Xena
the GBA got time for this
you want your wishes or what I don't
even know why I'm friends with you
Vinnie you stole Sandra you my mom
my entire life sucks because of you your
life sucks because of me my life sucks
because of you I wish we'd never met
[Music]
this is your wish this is your life and
you never met turtle pepper Snacks
what's wrong with me you dying bitch
dying but how well have you ever seen
that movie the Dallas buyers club I have
AIDS oh no no you were working on the
set and got cracking the bone with the
light damn well I work in movies that's
pretty cool
my producer is something no you're a
production assistant you get bagels
you're a bagel bitch so wait I'm
dying because I got hidden head little
lights not exactly have you ever seen
that movie in The Fault in Our Stars
what like work on that movie too and
fall of a crane nah you got cancer when
they brought you in for the bump on your
head they discovered the lung cancer as
well as the cirrhosis of your liver
Oh and now that I'm looking at your
charts here you actually do have AIDS
most me from all the dirty needles and
prostitutes you sick and this is
what my life is like well because I
never met Colonel yep well if my life
sucks this bad curls must be a pile of
yes again dick knows
I just want to thank every one of my
staff but most importantly I'd like to
thank my dear wife Sandra she inspired
me to run for president she was also
instrumental in passing the legislation
that allowed the acceleration of
Stanford University's stem-cell research
program what's that what do you say
ladies and gentlemen I've just been
informed that the research I had just
mentioned earlier has led to the cure
for all known diseases Colonel is the
president yeah without you colonel was
able to reach his full potential and
make the entire world a better place but
he said they found the cure for all
known diseases so I'm gonna be okay
right
oh no you put doctor your sister you
can't afford those drugs your ass don't
even get benefits to a bitch what
am I gonna do can I wish it back I wish
it back retarded oh you really can't say
that anymore
bitch I spent the last 30 years in a
turntable I'll say whatever the
hell I want
yeah that's that's not how things work
anymore
so you can go around talking about
your friend's mom but I can't
sleep retarded apparently man that's
gears Hill yikes let's just let's just
go back whoa where'd you guys go I
showed Vinnie what his life would be
like if you do it never met what was it
like Vinnie were you better off without
me why would you wish yourself back yeah
I mean it was it was awesome it was way
better but uh you know it really would
have been selfish for me to stay in that
other life so I decided to wish myself
back here for you wow that's amazing
Vinnie that's that's that's really nice
of you
Shh boy his life was an awesome he was a
bagel bitch died of AIDS and you was the
president what Vinnie is
that true yeah and you were married to
Sandra Wow
dick look Colonel I'm sorry for
being such a to you all these
years I'm really sorry that I banged
Sandra out from under you
it turns out I need you way more than
you need me I want to make up for all
that I want you to have the last wish
all right well I think I know what I
want to wish for I'm begging you colonel
please don't wish for that I was dying
man dying alone in a crappy Hospital I
don't want to die I don't want to be
alone
look at this day boy I'm begging for
he's retarded ants live like a little
bitch
second bigger dude you can't say those
things dude it's a whole thing with him
don't even bother now about your wish I
just want things to go back to how they
were Vinny before I broke your turntable
what you said you needed me Vinny that's
all I've ever wanted to hear I just want
things to go back to the way they were
you're my best friend I don't say that
so it's all I went to man I bet you do
you piece of
Oh